[音楽]
プー
グー
ません
私は1972年に生まれて日本で男女平等の教育を受けて大きくなりました
ですので1995年まあ今から24年前に仕事を始める時にも男女平等に働ける仕事に
就こうと思ったんですね
当時はまだそんなに女性が男性と全く同じ待遇で正社員として長く続けられる仕事は今
以上にありませんでしたでも同時にこれからの時代は女性も働き続けて働くだけじゃ
なくて家族も持つような新しい着方が出来るのよというようなことも言われていたん
ですね
だからじゃあ自分はいわば最も先進的な働き方をして経済的に事実をしようと思いまし
た
理由の一つは大黒柱だった父に耐えのおかげで食べていけると思っているんだなんて
言われたり
マーサ場所に悔しかったんですよねあとは母に女の人は経済力のある男性を捕まえない
と
幸せになれないわよって言われたのも捕まえられなかったらどうしようと思って不安
だったので
だったら自分が経済力を使い付けた方がいいだろうと
まあ思った
それで1995年に東京の大きなテレビ局に入りました放送局
アナウンサーという仕事を始めたんです
アナウンサーという仕事は会社員でありながらテレビやラジオに入れて
ニュースを読むこともあればバラエティーショーに出ることもあるまあ何でもやる
出演者という仕事でした
もちろん男性も女性もいますが男女の仕事の区別がありません
だから当然男女平等だったと平等だと思って働き始めたわけですが
働き始めてすぐにあることに気づきました入社早々のほとんど経験のないん
私たち若い女性アナウンサーに仕事が殺到するんです
それはそれが大人気でした最初ラッキーって思ったんですけど
セグにある違和感を覚えました
日本では女性アナウンサーに対する俗称で女子アナという言葉があります
これが誕生したのは30年前あるテレビ局が発明したんですけれども
なんと30年に渡って未だにこの女子アナというコンテンツは人気です
上司という言葉が使われているように非常に前だジェンダーステレオタイプ的な役割を
求められる
のが調子じゃないですつまり従順で可愛いくってニコニコしていてその場が華やぐよう
な男性がいいなあんなコトハ焼きたいなぁと思うような感じの良い若い女性をやること
が暗黙のうちに求められていたんです
だからどこに行っても女子アナっぽくとかじゃ
ロシアがらしく女子アナなのに女子アナのくせに
と言われました
おかしいなぁ男性と対等の立場で働いてるはずなのになんで私は小島慶子じゃなくて
どこに行っても女子アナって言われるんだろう
とても強い違和感を抱きました
気付いたんですいくら待遇が台頭であっても
制度が整っていても人々の良い式や文化が変わらなければ
性差別的なものっていうのはなくならないんだなということに
まあそれでもなんとかその会社でやっていかなくてはならないと思ってジタバタし
ながらも15年働いて30代半ばで私は会社を辞めました
おかげで今はもうその女子アナの呪いからは自由になりました
だけど
テレビに出て自分の思ったことをはっきり言ったりあるいは男性出演者と議論をしたり
すると生駅
失礼ヒステリーとネットでたたかれます
女性が思ったことを言っただけで環
男性と議論しただけで失礼ヒステリー
残念ながら私が新人女性アナウンサーとして女子アナという言葉に違和感を感じてから
24年経ってもいまだにそうした空気は根強いんですよね
ちょっとこちらの数字をご覧いただきたいんですが
なんだかいますか
黒 new して方わかるかな
世界経済フォーラムが毎年発表している
ジェンダーギャップ指数のランキングの日本の順位です
2016年111
2017年南2017年が114位
2018年が111また症状下はありますけれども一貫して先進国では g 7では最
下位です得に政治経済分野での責任ある立場で活躍する女性というのは著しく少ないと
いうのが日本のスコアを押し下げています
それはメディア業界も同じですし
様々な職場でやはり意思決定層は大多数が男性を閉めてより
また職場の文化というのはマッチョな男性文化であるというところは少なくないと思い
ます
でもここのところちょっと変化も出てきました
2017年アメリカに端を発したミーティムーブメントは日本にも上陸したんですね
そして勇気ある女性たちが声を上げました
非常に立場のある力のある男性から受けた性暴力やセクハラを勇気を持って告発した
女性たちがいたんですね
彼女たちに賛同してみーとぅーと声をあげる人たちもいました
でも残念ながら
それよりもはるかに大きな彼女たちに対するバッシングが起こったんです
声を上げた人がたたかれる被害訴えた人がたたかれる
女性が
一人称で顔と名前を出して被害を訴えることに対する
増や
偏見は非常に大きなものでした
結果としてそれじゃあナイスの伊藤史織さんは
活動の拠点を日本からイギリスに移さざるを得なくなりました
このままもうこの動きは止まってしまうかと危惧していたところその翌年
去年の4月ですね次の動きが起きました
これが大きな仕様目となりました
ある若い
テレビ局の女性記者が財務事務次官からセクハラ発言を受けていたことを告発しました
財務事務次官というのは官僚の中でも最も権威ある最も権力を持っている立場の
男性です
その人に対して1女性記者が告発したわけですね
この時も大変な被害者バッシングが起こりました
もしかしたらこのままこの事件はもみ消されてしまうのかと思いました
ところがメディアで働く女性たちが連帯して声をあげたんです
そしてそこから報道が変わりました
meet you やセクハラやその他のハラスメントに腰が引けていたメディアが
積極的にそれを報じるようになったんです
この時にある女性記者が行ったことが私の友人ですが忘れられません
男性が多い職場で女性が働くときにはセクハラなんかで泣き言言っちゃいけないと思っ
てた
セクハラなんてなんでもないって笑い飛ばすのが強くてカッコイイ女だと思ってたけど
間違ってた
もう二度と彼女みたいな被害者を出したくないからもうやめよ
も間違っている言わなきゃダメだよね涙ながらに語ったんですね
私はとても共感しました私にもそういう面があったからです
きっとそうじゃなければ生きてこられなかった女性たちは多いと思います
適用しなければ survive できないぐらい女性にとっては風当たりの強い職場
環境って世界中にあると思います
でも適用しなければ survive できないという構造そのものがおかしいと声を
あげる時が来たんだと
去年たくさんの日本の人たちが気がつきました
そして女性だけではなく多くのハラスメントに泣き寝入りをして働くというのはそう
いうものだ
男というのはそういうものだと自分の声を殺してきた男性たちもまた少しずつ声を上げ
始めたんです
つまり女性にとって生きづらい世の中は男性にとっても生きづらい世の中で男性たい
女性ではない
そうじゃなくて人間らしく働けるようの中にしようっていう声が去年日本で少しずつ
上がるようになってきました
これはとても大きな変化だったと思っています
実は私には個人的な経験もありまして
2013年に夫が仕事を辞めたんですね
そして私が一家の大黒柱になりました彼が仕事を辞めたときに私は大黒柱になる不安
から彼を責めてしまったんですね
なぜだぜなの仕事を辞めるの男のくせに
お金を稼いでない男の人をどうやって尊敬していいか分からないわ
あるいは私が稼いでるんだからね私のおかげであなたは食べていけるのよ
と言う
ひどい言葉を彼にぶつけてしまったんです私が父に言われて嫌だったことをぶつけて
しまいました
だから私の中にも私を苦しめてきた価値観は
内在していたということを発見したんですそこで仕事を辞めた彼を肯定するためにもの
の見方を変えるために環境を変えました
それが
引っ越しです
私が父の転勤先だったオーストラリアのパースというところで生まれて3年間過ごした
んですがそこに息子達を連れて一家4人で引っ越すことにしました
そして夫はハウサーずバンドとして子どもたちを一生懸命お世話し私は一家の大黒柱と
して日本とオーストラリアを行き来して
経済的に家族を支えるという生活を始めたんですもう丸5年経ちました
そこで私は2つのことを学びました一つは
私が
今日者としてにくんですがいた父のような働く男たちのしんどさを知ったということ
です
大黒橋ちゃってすごいプレッシャーです私が死んだらどうなるんだろう
明日仕事が無くなったらどうしよう
不安で押しつぶされそうです今の
特に飛行機で息をしていると飛行機がものすごく揺れるとまぁ飛行機揺れたぐらいで
落ちないんですけどそれでもこのまま落ちたらどうしようと心配になります夫と子供
たちが路頭に迷ってしまう
その時に父のことを思い出すんです父もそうだったんだろうな
だけどその父の不安や孤独に私も母までも1回の耳を傾けなかっ
や世の中も耳を傾けなかったんですよね
男女差別だとか男女の不平等がなくさなくてはなりません
もちろんです長い差別の歴史を生きてきた女性たちはどんな目にあってきたかというの
は男性は知るべきです
でもそれと同時に男性にどんな孤独や不安があったのかということも
知るべきですよね
男性の痛みを孤独には耳を貸す価値がないっていうのも
フェアではないと思いました
そのことに気づいたのがまず一つ目の気づきです
そしてもう一つそう思って私の夫を見てみたら
夫は
男として仕事を辞めたら負け犬だと言われる社会の中で自分で選んで仕事を辞めました
きっといろんなことを言われたと思います
悪口も言われたしちょうしょうもされたかも知れませ
そして全く生活したことのない場所で新しい生活を始めてから英語は全然堪能ではない
ので英語の勉強もしながら誰も知り合いのいない場所で
1から新生活を立ち上げたんですよね
引っ越して2年経った時子どもたちがオーストラリア大好きって言いました
前にすごく楽しそうで学校でも何の問題もなくすごくハッピーに暮らしているのを発見
した時に
私は夫がこの2年どれだけ苦労をしてどれだけ頑張って来たかっていうの
に気付いたんですそれまでは自分が大黒柱で大変だってことで頭がいっぱいだったけど
彼がどれだけ勇気のいるどれだけ大冒険を成し遂げたのかってことに気がつきました
彼は一銭もお金を稼いでいないし何の肩書もないけれど
なんて強い人なんだろうなんで頼りになる人なんだろう
私は生まれて初めて
そういう形で彼を一人の人としてリスペクトしました
そのような眼差しをパートナーに向けることができて本当に良かったと思いました
それは私にとって大きな学びであり私たち家族にとってとても豊かなことだったから
です
経済成長を続けていた日本はこれから先
みんなが働きながらしかも大切な人との暮らし
例えば子供だったりあるいは高齢化して親の介護だったりというのをやっていかないと
生きていけない者会になりました
らしさの押しつけで幸せになる人は誰もいません
人間らしく働きながら大切な人と生きていく
それから思いがけないことがたくさん起こる人生自分の病気になるかもしれないし何が
起こるか分からない
災害があるかもしれない思いがけないことがたくさんある人生でその登記さの時
いろいろな生き方を選択できるような
社会であってほしいですよね
そうじゃないぷ誰も安心して生きていけないしらしさの押し付けではお互いに苦しい
ばかりです
今日のテーマは find new パ
ここから新しい未来に向かっての道を開くだけではなくてすぐ身の周りにいた人
もしかしたら自分にとっては的に見えていたり仲間じゃない人に見えてきた痛いうん
当時面と違っていた共通点なんか何もないと思ってる人との間にも実は道が通じてるん
です
見方を変えればその人のところに行って一緒に手をとって
もう世の中を変えていこうみんなでハッピーになれる世の中を作ろうって一緒に声を
上げる
仲間は実は私たちの身の回りにたくさんいるんです
私はそれを自分のすぐ隣にいる夫の中にあるいはもうなくなってしまったけれど私が
ずっと
ステロタイプに捉えてきた私の父の中にも見つけることができました
どうか皆さんも
少し見方を変えてみてくださいあなたの神動作をシェアできる人はあなたのすぐ近くに
いるかもしれません
ありがとうございました
[拍手]